اصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين بالرصاص المعدني في
مواجهات اندلعت بين محتجين فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها
لمنطقه قبر يوسف بمدينه نابلس شماليه
الضفه الغربيه المحتله واستعملت فيها
قنابل غاز ادى الى عشرات من حالات
الاختناق وجاء اقتحام جنود الاحتلال
المنطقه بهدف تمكين مجموعات من المستوطنين
من الوصول الى منطقه قبر يوسف وذلك لاقامه
طقوس تلموديه فيه وقد استخدمت قوات
الاحتلال جرافه لازاله سواتر ترابيه
واطارات وضعها شبان في الشارع المؤدي
للقبر لعرقله الاقتحام واعاقه باصات
المستوطنين
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال 19 فلسطينيا خلال
حمله اعتقالات شنتها في بلدات وقرى ومدن
فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك
القدس المحتله ومنعت قوات الاحتلال اطقم
الاسعاف من الوصول الى احد المصابين بعد
وقوع اشتباكات مع مسلحين ومواجهات مع شباب
مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا وفي بلده قباطيه
جنوبي جنين انسحبت قوات الاحتلال بعد
فشلها في اعتقال احد الشبان كما اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال بلده سعيا شمالي رام الله
وقريه كفر قدوم في قلقيليه واعتقلت عددا
من الفلسطينيين بعد دهن بيوتهم في مدينه
الخليل وفي بلده العيساويه بالقدس المحتله
على البلد نزل على البلد شباب